with summer right around the corner we
could all use a little fun and nothing
scream fun
nothing screams fun like toys and here
was some of the hottest toys on the
market this summer is senior editor and
the toy uh excuse me my god leo help me
it is okay
do you want me to read it for you yes
leo thank you here are some of the
hottest toys on the market this summer
is
this summer is senior editor of the toy
insider sandy maholic how are you i'm
great how are you
nice to see you again thank you it's
great to be back
[Applause]
well who better to help me review
um than my dear dear
dear friend the one and only leo kelly
the shirley temple king
thank you so much for having me on again
thank you for bringing all these tips
maddie mahalik thank you so much for um
being here today i mean what's it like
to be in your job i have the best job
ever playing with the coolest toys of
the year all right maddie what toy do we
have first yeah we are ready to play
right so let's start off with can jam
you guys go over to that can over there
and grab the two discs over here so this
is you go on the other side with leo
so this is a super fun frisbee flying
disc game that the whole family can play
so you guys are going to try to get the
frisbee over right here and i'm going to
try to smack it in
oh and if you really want to try to get
an ultimate victory you can get it right
in this slot here i'm being completely
honest with all you i am horrible at
throwing a frisbee oh it has a mind of
its own it's like oh i'm a frisbee oh
you want to go straight no i'm going to
go this way
yeah well let's see it let's test it out
let's see how crazy your frisbee goes
oh
see that was pretty good
it wasn't bad it was not bad all right
let's see what you got that's true oh
see we are close mine was a way further
out all right can jam um leo
thoughts
thoughts for me it's a great outdoor
party game that's what i really really
love about it plus you can make like
challenges and goals and like trick
shots you could be like oh can i make it
from here can i make it with my eyes
closed from here
it's really really fun because you
there's different styles you can play it
right okay maddie what's next all right
so both of you take a seat on either
side of this treasure chest so we're
gonna go on an epic adventure with the
kinetic sand treasure hunt
this is my favorite yeah so you can
bring the beach with you anywhere with
this kinetic sand compound which feels
just like sand but it will never dry out
so this treasure chest over here is
filled with a bunch of different
surprises so start digging through
there's stuff in there yeah and see what
you can find i have a joke for you guys
what did the pirates say when you turned
80.
i maybe get it like i'm easy
was that a good one that was a very good
one oh i found something oh let's go
what do you call an eagle with no hair
no clue a bald eagle oh
that's awesome all right so you can dig
around for treasure leo thoughts
i love this genre of toys because you
don't just oh you're not just like oh i
open it oh it's done you really gotta
absorb it take your time plus you can
like reuse the kinetics hand put it in a
bag there's so many different things you
could do with it and oh you know what
let's show this
you take this like pasta dough you
flatten it
and you use this it's a cookie cutter
we know i love you
all right maddie what's up we gotta keep
on moving all right
come on join me over here
so this is the giant giraffe ring
sprinkler and it is eight feet tall this
is like three of leo kelly's that's
right
i know it looks i mean it's big to me i
can't even imagine it's so easy to use
you just hook it up to a hose and water
will start flying out of its nose
put a hose yes but you can also play
without water which is still super fun
so want to try to shoot some baskets in
the middle of the ring
let's go guys
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing but not clear
[Music]
you